for Hong Kong and for China I think you
know they certainly have a history of
very cheap and very very good and that
bit in the middle is is wide open and I
just think you know also if you look at
the general population and kind of how
they're earning and working I think this
is a logical realistic relevant thing to
do where you've chosen to cite it in
Causeway Bay and you know is the target
market the indigenous is it the tourists
is it the businessman what what do you
think is what do you think is gonna work
I mean it's a great brand your global
people know who you are I think you'll
get a bit of expat sort of extra love I
think tourism always works very well I
think our main focus will always be on
the locals you know I think the culture
that we have and we have obviously
multiple sites so you know the culture
is the only thing you have it's not me
there's only one of me you know really
tapping into neighborhood making it a
reliable neighborhood place to eat you
know and I think also with James Italian
and the way that we structure our spend
per head you know it is very affordable
but then when you walk in there's fresh
pasta and bread getting made every day
and you get that you know those values
so III think our challenge will always
be the locals always where do we go if I
say to you okay this this is Hong Kong
which I suppose has its own very
individual hallmarks but is this the
first footprint on a bigger China on a
bigger China venture or is it just
another step in in a pretty pretty
aggressive expansion of James's target
just growing massively is not the
sexiest thing in the world
it's a massive headache and choosing the
right partners and growing organically
and at the right pace is really
important and certainly from myself
there ain't no points for rolling out
ten crappy restaurants you know we do
one we get it right I think with our
partners of course that they've got
their mind on other cities in China and
I'll take I mean it's totally their
decision you know I'll get to sort of
see location restaurants and sort of you
know get to approve it from the UK point
of view but really I think it's about
trusting them but also speed is not the
biggest appetite here